is many nations it led the news
the us inauguration was relayed in
dozens of languages
and leaders translated what it would
mean for their countries
frankly said these have not been four
easy years that we've had with donald
trump
someone who as us president calls europe
along with russia and china
the biggest opponents of the united
states so
a lot has gone wrong there with joe
biden there is now someone in the white
house who wants to repair the
trans-atlantic partnership
in russia tv networks focused on
soldiers around the capital
with one channel comparing it to a
private party inside
a besieged fortress in a beijing news
conference
china's foreign ministry spokeswoman
spoke candidly of a challenging last
four years
i think the new administration should
serve the wishes of the people
view china in a rational and objective
light and work with china
on the basis of mutual respect equality
and mutual benefit
iran's foreign ministry followed that
sentiment in this video it tweeted
calling trump's foreign policy
diplomatic vandalism
and tweeting the world knows that only
the us can fix itself
in practice not just words
israel however was hopeful iran remains
in america's crosshairs i look forward
to working with you
to further strengthen the u.s israel
alliance to continue expanding peace
between israel and the arab world
and to confront common challenges chief
among them
the threat posed by iran
kamala harris's indian ancestry was
celebrated by prime minister narendra
modi
who called it an historic occasion
harris's maternal grandmother comes from
this village near the southern indian
city of chennai
we are very happy we are very proud
harris made history as the first person
of south asian descent to become
u.s vice president america
we are very happy right now things
brings us hope that we can also achieve
whatever we want
even being a woman she is a role model
for the villagers
and girls here inside america there were
calls for unity
outside there was hope of unity too of
tighter ties and renewed relations
to tackle some of the world's biggest
issues together
charlotte dallas al jazeera